there are familiar sight in Goma
cuckoo dues cargo carrying scooters made
in Congo
durable wood and patient craftsmanship
are what it takes to make them Sebastian
and Pascal learned how from his father
he charges $100 for two kudu it's pretty
hard work the most difficult part is
whittling everything down so that the
parts fit together do mock with
Republican almost all the parts come
from the region Pascal and his
colleagues go at it for up to three days
until everything fits only then is the
chickadee ready to roll it not only
transports people but staggering loads
of just about anything
in downtown DOMA a statue has been
erected in honor of this prized means of
transportation
we used to not have things like
motorcycles but we have the chuka do to
help us transport goods it was invented
here in Goma that's why we have this
statue this to could do reflects kamas
image
it symbolizes our city and that makes us
happy who knows it's got no food i shows
how they have to work so hard just in
their life here in Goma meanwhile
Sebastian Pascal has arrived at his
family home his sister is proud of the
hard-working - kudu constructor we have
enough to eat and send the kids to
school Pascal was convinced that hard
work is the only way forward in
crisis-ridden eastern Congo and so he's
on the road again hauling new wood for
the next two gudule